hey everybody welcome back to code 30
things in 30 days with css3 today is day
number 9 and we are going to be building
some modern layouts using CSS we're
going to be using some media queries and
we're gonna play around to create some
modern layouts so I'm going to show you
here in my browser the final result I'm
going to scroll down here we have modern
layout number one just the tad this is
basically just a structure so we're not
creating like a web page or anything per
se we're actually just almost of wire
framing in the browser so you can see
here we have the header this blue
background is what delineates the header
down here we have an article with body
text and over here we have an aside so
we're using html5 for this and then the
bottom we have a footer and so we're
gonna style that to create that layout
and then obviously you can use that
layout to create modern basic modern
blog layout modern layout number two we
have a header up here again with a logo
on the left side and simple navigation
on the right side we have a left-hand
sidebar using an aside html5 tag an
article in the center and then a
right-hand content sidebar and then the
footer and modern layout number three we
have basically a little bit of a
flipping on the header here so we have
the navigation on the left the logo on
the right then three articles and a
three column grid and then the footer
and so up here we're gonna be working
with that in our sandbox
we have the I have the HTML already
written for you all you have to do is
use the CSS to create those layouts and
so we're gonna do that today
in this lesson day number nine let's
jump into our code editor so download
modern layouts in this lesson go ahead
and do that and get yourself started
pause the video do what you need to do
and then open up the sandbox CSS feel
free to familiarize yourself with the
code to the HTML and the final CSS so
this is the HTML you could see here that
in the sandbox we're using teh html5 tag
so sections headers articles asides and
footers and we're just
identifying each section with a class so
that we know which section we are
styling in our CSS and is a little bit
more involved in each example in each
layout example and then in the final CSS
you can see all of the final CSS so if
you need to go ahead and refer to that
for a reference or anything like that
you can certainly do that jump in your
sandbox let CSS and let's get started
with the very first layout modern layout
number one all right let's start it with
the class of layout one article so I'm
selecting the class of layout one in our
inner index here you can see each of the
sections are titled with a class layout
one two and three respectively we're
gonna start with layout one article
we're gonna give it a width of 58% and
then we're going to float that left
let's move down and style the layout one
aside we're going to simply give that a
width of 40% and float that right and
then we're going to go ahead and say
layout 1 and then footer we're gonna
clear both because we want we need a
clear fix for that that's going to
create an issue is gonna collapse the
two floats are gonna collapse that on
each other so the footer is gonna create
an issue I don't actually just hide that
for now and let's see what we have in
our browser let's head over to our
sandbox and you can see here the header
is fine we haven't done anything with
the header we have the article which is
the will the article tag and it's
floated at 58% and then we have the
aside at 40% so those fit nicely but of
course the footer here is collapsed up
into those elements and that's because
it needs to be cleared it's a very
common web design issue when you're
coding with floats so all we have to do
here in our browser sorry in our code
editor is clear:both you can do clear
left or clear right but we're gonna
clear both so that we can just get it
over with so now back in our browser you
can see that that modern layout number
one is complete and it looks fantastic
that literally took seconds now let's
move down to modern layout number two
this one is where we're going to have
logo be on the left side the navigation
on the right we're going to play with
the aside the article and the aside so
we have two sidebars and content in the
center so jump back in your code editor
give yourself some space and we're going
to add modern layout number two using
our styling conventions we're going to
select layout to the class and then
we're going to select the header within
that and then logo so a pretty specific
selector and we're gonna say width for
the logo is 20% we're going to float
that left and then we're going to give
it a margin of zero now if we go below
that we're going to do another thing
here and we're gonna say layout to
header and nav all html5 tags here
trying to be as semantic as possible
with 78% and we're gonna say float:right
margin:0 let's save that and see what
happened in our browser so we have the
layout looking nice for the logo and the
navigation we're using the 20% and 78%
and the problem here is the parent
container the header has collapsed on
itself because now it has nothing to
hold it open and that's where we're
going to use a clear fix so let's jump
back into our code editor and we're
going to do a little bit more solid of a
clear fix here it's a little bit
different because this is the parent
container that's collapsing rather than
a sibling element that kind of collapses
within a you know up into those the
layout that we created in our modern
layout number one the parent container
here is collapsing on itself so we're
going to do a little bit different of a
clear fix so I'm gonna say and it's it's
very simple and very nice so we're gonna
say layout - header this is going to be
a virtual last child
a little pseudo-element there
and then we're gonna say display is
table content will be just an empty
string and then we're gonna clear both
that's gonna create an element pseudo
elements using the header after so at
the end of the header there's the kind
of a ghost element that you can create
using this pseudo element here and we're
gonna make a display table that can't
collapse the content has to be an empty
string for these pseudo elements because
if there is no content it won't appear
but if you have content and we're just
gonna have an empty string you could put
text in here and that will show up but
we don't want that and clear:both just
to cover our bases let's head over and
see what happened in our browser bay
over here we're gonna go down to modern
layout - and that solved the problem
right here so the logo the navigation
and the header all look good because of
our simple clear fix to prevent collapse
let's move on back on our code editor
we're gonna jump down and we're going to
style our article so we're gonna say a
layout to article I'm gonna give that a
width of 50 percent of the entire
container parent container margin left
we're gonna say 2 percent and we're
gonna float that left and let's select
again here the layout to a side and the
class of side nav so that is the aside
html5 tag with the class of side nav so
that is going to be a navigation on
probably the left-hand side here
let's say it's width is 23% and we're
gonna float that left and then let's
move down one more layout - and we're
gonna say a side and a side bar which
will be on the right-hand side and we're
gonna say wid 23% and we're gonna float
that right
we're gonna save that check it out in
our browser modern layout number two so
we have excuse me our left navigation
bar here our article and our sidebar
great the problem is our footer is
collapsing up into those elements you
guess that we need to clear fix but
we're just gonna we're just gonna
actually just do a simple clear rather
than the the clear fix we used for the
header so let's select the layout too
and then we're gonna select footer and
simply say clear both that will solve
the problem over here in our browser
that looks good modern layout number two
beautiful now let's jump into modern
layout number three that one is going to
be with the logos on the right the
navigations on the left three column
grid for the articles and then the
footer at the bottom so let's jump back
into our code editor and we're going to
give it a little comment here and say
modern layout number three and let's
select layout three header and then logo
width is 20% float:right and margin zero
lay out three header nav and we're gonna
say width 78 percent float:left and then
margin zero and now that is going to
create a problem with the header being
collapsed like we did before so we can
type that out again layout number three
header pseudo-element
after we're gonna display table we're
gonna add the content as an empty string
and clear of both I will solve the
problem for that so let's go back and
check out modern layout number three our
header looks perfect with our navigation
and our logo now let's make those that
three column grid with the articles
we're gonna say layout three three
article I'm going to select all of them
we're gonna say width 32 percent
float:left and margin zero two percent
zero zero now if I save that and we view
that in our browser let's see what we
have we it looks like we have an issue
so we have two articles here the other
article is falling down here and it's
falling behind the final result element
so it is one two and three so there's a
problem there let's jump back over the
reason what that problem is in fact just
to tell you is there's a two percent
margin on the right of each of these
articles so that means there's no space
for it to fit on this right side so if
we remove that 2% margin on that last
element it will fit perfectly fine so
let's go ahead and do that so I'm just
gonna have a comment so we know what's
going on clear the margin the last
article to allow it to fit within the
layout simple layout three article last
child we're selecting the last child
cool css3 trick there margin zero so
instead of giving it an ID or a class
and then styling that class just Messi's
not very semantic we're just using CSS
to style that we're not messing with the
presentation or the HTML we're just
specifically using css3 to fix that
problem
awesome now this is going to create
collapse which we've seen so we're going
to do the simple clear fix again we're
going to go lay out three we're going to
select the articles element that is the
parent element of the three html5
articles and the after pseudo element at
the end of the articles div we're gonna
say display table content empty string
clear both that will solve that problem
let's view that in our browser all right
and here we are modern layout number
three that way it looks awesome we have
everything lined up the footer is being
cleared so we don't have any more
problems there that looks good and now
we could leave it as is but it wouldn't
be a modern layout if it wasn't
responsive so we're just gonna do a
really simple responsive fix here so if
I were to actually adjust this you can
see that the percentage maintains the
layout but the text it doesn't really
look very good so it's not actually that
nice so the layout will maintain
regardless of the size of the window but
we don't actually want that because you
have two to three words per line and
that's incredibly unreadable and we
don't want that so basically all I want
to do is remove all the floats and the
width and just reset that so everything
stacks when you get to 768 pixels which
is like a like a brand new iPhone in
[Music]
horizontal or landscape viewport mode so
let's go over to our sandbox at CSS and
we're going to leave a comment and I'm
just gonna say simple media queries for
responsive layouts and then we're gonna
select the media at media screen and
there's there's many ways to write media
queries this way is just a nice simple
way of selecting a specific
so this is media screen and max-width in
parentheses the value is 768 pixels that
means screens not print or like a like a
real like a reading device like a Kindle
or something like that
screens such as your computer or mobile
devices and max-width this is the most
important part of the media query the
max width of the viewport being 768
pixels and you can find that information
online really easily the viewports the
common view ports for excuse me media
queries so I'm going to select layout
one I'm gonna do this basically combine
a whole bunch of selectors here so
article comma I'm gonna go lay out one
side lay out two header logo lay out two
header nav lay out two article lay out
two side and the class of side nav and
also class of sidebar and then we're
going to go lay out three article lay
out three side lay out three header the
class of something with the header with
the class of logo I'm selecting logo
within header whoops
comma just one more here lay out three
header nav now it's possible I could
have what I could have done here instead
of written everything out has just
selected all articles all the sides all
headers but then I also have to select
all logos side nav sidebars that would
be fine to be probably in fact it would
be a much cleaner selector but I just
wanted to be specific in this case
float:none width 100% and the margin and
a reset everything to zero two percent
sorry zero zero two percent
like that save it and then check it out
in your browser let's see how these all
stack when I make this viewport smaller
so 7 6 th pop up here seen there we go
thousand 68 around there so yeah switch
so now all the layouts just stack and
they have 2% margin on the bottom of
each element so it's just a nice simple
responsive layout so those are some
basic modern layouts using css3 and
media queries that's it for today's
lesson day 9 modern layouts hope this
sheds some valuable insight onto on how
to use css3 to create some pretty
straightforward layouts a lot of these
layouts are what you see in common and
popular web pages nowadays and these
these layouts kind of concepts you can
modify them and change all the sizes and
the Wits and and organize things and
whatever way you want and that's the
beauty of css3 or you have the
flexibility to do literally whatever you
want in terms of creating layouts so
hopefully those examples were nice and
simple and kind of gave you some ideas
thanks for hanging out with me today
with day number 9 and I'll see you
tomorrow for day 10
[Music]